this film
is a film where four teachers
are trying to prove a theory that
humankind has been born
or should have been born with a little
bit of alcohol in the blood
to increase creativity courage
presence and it's a film that hopefully
becomes
about being inspired in life in general
and not just a movie about alcohol
one of the school teachers is martin and
martin is a man
in his early 50s whose life has come to
a standstill
with his job with his family with his
dreams
we get to learn that he was actually a
fantastic school teacher once
and the very earliest scene everything
dawns in marching
when everybody's having a great time he
just realizes that he the trainers left
him and he's standing on the platform
and he has
a small breakdown and this is where the
film
takes a turn and one of his colleagues
and his friends is
coming up with this theory he's heard
that we're all born with too little
alcohol in our blood and that might be
something that could help me out my
mystery as well
as heavy as you are in the beginning and
what you just described beautifully
as a train having left your station to
fly at the end i think that's the scene
people want to hear us talk about
[Music]
what a life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but it makes me terrified to be on the
other side
[Music]
but it makes me terrified to be on the
other side
[Music]
what a beautiful beautiful
[Music]
it's okay it's okay
[Applause]
it's okay
i don't know
[Music]
[Music]
what a beautiful beautiful
throughout the film they've been talking
a little about his former life
as a amateur dancer but that steam
was that always part of the idea as an
ending for this film it was floating
back and forth as you know tobias
lindholm
our dear friend and my co-writer on this
film
is a reality rules kind of guy so he was
confronting me with the dangers of
making this
dancing but i sort of kept insisting on
it and he said well
in that case we have to prepare it then
we started to discuss is this a middle
of a movie or an end of a movie
probably because i talked i had a
conversation with
fellow danish director la fontrio once
where we talked about writing
he said the only thing i've learned
about writing
is that you have to save the best for
the end which to some extent
has a simplicity to it which i ended up
following in this case
it was a risky to say that will be the
best that we are saving
for the end because we had our doubts
whether we could pull that off
i think i took the position of
protecting it because i had a feeling
that this could be cathartic but i was
always very nervous about it
we felt it was a bit of a stretch i
guess that a school teacher suddenly
ends in a musical kind of scene
in in in an in the end of a movie which
is supposed to be very real
one thing i realized building up to that
sequence was not only the other guys
talking about it's actually the theme of
the song
is being you know suggested to us
throughout the film a few times
and i never really thought about that
it's something we want to hear we want
to hear the rest of that song as well
and then finally i also get a good
excuse to dance to it
the whole theme of this movie is the
loss of control
we've placed the film in a society
that is very controlled it's a
performance culture
measuring each other being measured all
the time graded
all the time and here are four men who
breaks free of that
and even more so it came a movie that
landed in a confinement
with even more restricted lives so we
take
very controlled very restricted lives
and in a pandemic
and then out of that grows an urge
to lose control with that came for me an
urge
for you to let go physically to lose
physical
control which i think you so beautifully
and courageously did
at the end believing that idea and
having faith in this idea
i guess it was an ultimate loss of
control but i mean there's a lot of
reasons why i think it worked
first of all it's not about a man
dancing aesthetically it's about he's in
a journey that's that's the key point
obviously he's just
lost someone he loved dearly and he's
regained someone that he loves dearly
within the last hour
so it became like a more the inner
journey of dancing as opposed to the
aesthetic of dancing
and secondly it was also never supposed
to be
him doing something and people looking
at it he was just among a lot of other
people who were dancing
in a different way not physically but
flying on a high note
and i think that combination with all
the build up made us
capable of pulling it off because our
fear was that
we would stand up as being pretentious
trying to do something that was not
there
but once i saw the kids and the
immortality of these youngsters in real
life and and
what a great day they had on the film it
just became very clear that
i think we can actually pull it off i
felt it was very important to both you
and me
that when you sat on the bench and
looked at the war
you looked at our dead friend tommy so
that the scene became
a salute to him to some extent and the
last thing that he said to me that he
was cheering on me and my wife because
we were also
afraid obviously that all right so he's
you know in a fantastic world no he's
just lost his friend but
that we wanted to bring him into this we
should be a little nervous whether he
wants to fly a fall at the same time
i think we did that and not forgetting
your beautiful wife helena
she was obviously in the monitor tent so
every time we had a little discussion
technically
or how we should approach it after a
take we could always look at her because
she was sitting there beaming
and then we knew that we were on the
right track she gave us some energy
there
it's no secret match that of course in
the movie you were dancing for tommy
but in our lives you were dancing for my
precious daughter and my family wanted
to see that
and helene who always had complete faith
in this
film from it was like nothing has been
rooting for this
and obviously she had a very important
role that they
to keep rooting for to give us and there
was a lot of
on steak because there was tommy in the
movie and that was
my daughter in real life and there was
so much going on that day
it became not just a cathartic moment in
the movie but
in my career of making movies somehow
quite simply it is the symbol of the
tribute to life that this film
is and that scene is obviously showing
it more than other scenes
it has an open end we talked a lot about
what happened
after that open end as you remember you
fell into the water and there was some
more dialogue
we had a scene where you were crawling
to a public bus
but ending in the air like in 400 blows
in the french movie it was open which
has meant a lot to
a lot of people has raised a lot of
questions what does this actually mean
do you want us to drink do you not want
us to drink is he flying
is he falling where do you want to go
with us
i mean listening to the lyrics of the
song the second time i watched the film
i mean i've obviously
been dancing it over and over again but
somehow i didn't
pay the same kind of attention to the
lyrics but listening to it the second
time i saw the film
it was obviously what what it was about
the lyrics of basically saying you know
okay this is happening this has happened
but at all
all i want to do now is just be young
and alive for five more minutes
that's kind of the soul of the film in
many ways
it's the song is almost like it's
rebellious isn't it
it's like insisting on the right to let
go
my wife came in there we couldn't find
that song for a year i was chasing uh
super expensive rides internationally
and she just kept pointing at this
danish band and
the song is unseparable from the movie
the theme of the film always
being all these youngsters being drunk
and middle-aged men
experimenting to improve their lives
through drinking
and the elite singer it turned out when
i met him and my daughter
told me that i do know him because she
was friends with him when they were
youngsters and graduating from school
and at least twice i've picked him
and her up from the same party and
dropped him off at his mom when he was
absolutely hammered so there is some
kind of like
if not beautiful at least a poetic
circle with that that he's he ends up
being the lead singer of the
of the final dance number is he flying
or falling
oh always flying i love the idea and i
love that what we shot and i also
if you're an actor it is super cold and
you
you do kind of a cool stunt in the air
and land on your face in the water
there's a fairly big part of you who
wants that in the film
but i think that would have been a
disastrous ending i i do want to see him
up there
but i wasn't sure until we wrapped up
the film
that uh then i wasn't in doubt that this
film had to end up there
you know i i talked to quite a few
people who
says of course he's falling he starts
drinking again and instead of going home
to his wife he starts drinking
and falls into the water and falls in
yeah but he's he's on his way he's on
his way he just wants five more minutes
for this
he gets another round with his wife
that's what we believe in and then tommy
loses his life in the loss of control he
loses his life
yeah and also because we were busy with
our own
things we kind of forgot each other in
this experiment
we never saw that his issue was
different than our issue so we had our
head stuck
somewhere which is also obviously an eye
opener for these four guys that
why didn't they see it coming why were
they so busy with themselves
thomas who plays tommy we've known him
for many years
and it's publicly known that he's an
anonymous alcoholic
and i wonder how this film ends for him
i haven't asked him
but i'm not sure it ends in the same way
as we think
i i think it ends the same place for him
knowing thomas yes it's also the last
word she says
as a character to my character you can
say a lot of things about thomas but
he is a romantic and he's a poetic
person uh i think it does end on a high
note
yeah he was the one i talked to a lot in
the beginning
uh as you know this the script was
solely a celebration of alcohol in the
very start right
and i had some conversations with him of
course tobias dad was
had problems of the same kind and thomas
he just showed me some reality which was
uh
important at that point was widening the
perspective
and was putting tobias and me on track
towards wanting to show both the dark
side and
the light side of of drinking you never
wanted to be moral about it you never
wanted to be
a moral lesson about alcohol
the idea was always that the alcohol was
the kickstarter to tell a film about
how can you embrace life with or without
alcohol
so matt how many takes did we do how
many dances did you do
all in all uh right yeah it started
raining a little and
for some funny reason directors and and
dops love people to be doing stuff on
cobblestones as well
but once we did it the first time it was
just like it was just like just do it
let's get out there let's
jump into it and then and then and
actually there was a part of me that was
just
that was a little personally free as
well because i haven't done this for 30
years and i was super rusty but i i
really did enjoy it once we threw
ourselves into it
and those kids enjoyed it they did they
got it there was quite a few of them
that was there was cobbling the moves in
the background sometimes it was really
cool
there was this choreographer she came up
with some steps that you'd never seen
before because it was 30 years ago
something happened in 30 years that's
for sure but she was sweet enough to
you know let me make it my own i mean
she was the base of it she came up with
the base but then she added a beer
can and we tried to make it something i
could recognize as well but it was
basically her
step i'm trying to think now that i mean
besides
the energy of what you wanted did you
tell specifically how you wanted it to
end and what you wanted us to go through
i wanted i wanted you to fly at the end
that that for sure because i was
building stuff that you could jump
off from and stuff and then i wanted the
chewing and throwing
i wanted you to dance a little bit then
retreat a little bit and dance a little
bit more and then retreat and then
finally
give in and i wanted lars your friend to
encourage you yeah yeah
and stuff and you and i were very keen
on the bench
so there was actually some some steps
like a little bit of dancing
and then retreating to a bench
remembering that this is about
tommy who died right right
so that was phase one and phase two the
base kicking in
you not being able to stop yourself from
jumping over the bench
and it becomes sort of a camaraderie
loving
thing where you stop dancing and magnus
yeah
and you kick a beer thing that was sort
of phase two
then it kicks off and then you do your
circle
and your legs switch and then when they
all start singing
and pumping champagne on you it's the
flying
it's the ultimate running around those
were the faces that we shot it in this
these were the sequences
we divided it in when we shot it it's
one of these things
when you're an actor if there's certain
things you you're
quite good at and you're supposed to be
bad at it and
you can get so annoyed that the woman
will know that i can actually do that
and last had it he had that feeling all
day because he's actually a really good
dancer himself
and he could easily pull those moves off
that i did in the beginning
but he had to be a little drunk and
clungy and fall and i remember him being
so
just you know burning inside for like
just give me one shot at it you know
and it was just so sweet well what i can
say is it was
if not the most memorable day of
shooting in my career
than at least one of them for a lot of
reasons it was for a lot of reasons that
was
everything was just one gigantic
son of emotions right throughout the
film but just basically culminating
for you and your family and everyone
that day
so it's very hard to separate your life
from that ending i guess forever thanks
mass
you